the number one
puppet master and this is really their
word not mine that is now being blamed
not only for orchestrating Trump's
possible arrest happening Tuesday but
also Ron desantis's campaign is
this might not come as a surprise the
nearly 100 year old Jewish man George
Soros I know how could he be controlling
everything how could it be so effective
it doesn't make any sense well this is
where they're going we already have
multiple clips from the past few days
where on Fox News and elsewhere
the right is already starting to say
Soros is involved in what may be the
arrest of trump here's one clip from I
believe this is the weekend Fox and
Friends uh March 19th yeah I believe
this is the weekend Fox and Friends
talking about how Soros and globalists
must be to blame here so let me ask you
the question how many black lives have
you sacrificed under a higher crime city
with increased murder rates to devote a
limited number of resources to the
priority of pursuing a weak case against
Donald Trump how many black lives was
this political stunt worth what you
learn from the left is that they don't
really care about black lives or the
working class or the poor you know this
is a George Soros funded D.A and he has
to pay his master back and this is
exactly what his master folks this is oh
my goodness oh just overtly copying the
anti-semite rhetoric of the it's the
Jewish master who must be paid he wants
money that money grubbing
90-something-year-old
multi-billionaire George Soros wait that
does that make doesn't matter this is
the story George Soros and so many of
those uh
rap into Donald Trump they want to put
an end to him
um you know at George Soros a globalist
no question that Donald Trump and his
ideas which are now being yeah globalist
internationalist trotskyite socialists
unlike Obama Trudeau macron there it is
and by the way we'll get to what Alex
Jones thinks about all this a little bit
later Marjorie Taylor green also
invoking George Soros they're all on
message you've got to hand it to them it
is a war it's a political war
um and that is what they've waged
against President Trump his
administration his staff his supporters
and anyone that aligns himself with mega
and what this D.A this Manhattan D.A is
talking about doing he is serving his
master who is George Soros there it is I
mean folks it's quite literally the same
language this is Marjorie Taylor green
on pillow TV earlier it was you know the
weekend second stringers on Fox and
Friends they are on message that is for
damn sure and the Democrat Party in the
global list the lates that do not care
about America they don't care about
Americans anymore they see Trump as
their number one enemy and Maga is the
force that they have to take out and
that is why this D.A is considering
indicting president Trump all right so
Soros and the globalist
are the ones responsible but it's not
just for Trump's arrest they are also
claiming that Soros is responsible for
Ron desantis's potential candidacy which
hasn't even started yet there's a
handful of these I could play but I will
only play one this is just a random
person waiting in line at Trump's recent
event in Iowa bringing up oh no no Soros
is behind DeSantis is anybody talking
about any other person for president
other than Donald J Trump any other name
yeah there you go Soros money is behind
DeSantis as well so this is there's a
lot of scholarship about this and just
to be like completely accurate let me
just say 92 years old okay so he's not
quite yet approaching a hundred but he's
in his 90s the idea behind the Soros
conspiracy theories the person doing it
isn't necessarily intending to promote
anti-Semitism they may not even really
understand the whole back story but we
have to be realistic and George soros's
Jewish identity is widely known and the
origins of many of these conspiracies
are linked to those who understand and
are aware now I know some of you will
say well some of these people don't
necessarily know that Soros is Jewish I
grant you that but it's still important
to understand that the Soros conspiracy
theories are in extra linked in
um to very well-known anti-semitic
tropes like for example
Soros Rich Jewish guy controlling
banking or controlling Media or working
to destabilize a country or working to
infiltrate modern society with Marxism
or whatever the case may be and it all
goes back to those anti-semitic tropes
that many of us know all too well and
it's important to understand sort of
like the Genesis of that so Soros really
a busy guy now at 92
involved in DeSantis campaign and
Trump's arrest and all of it the
question next becomes whatever it is
that these right-wingers believe about
the possible arrest of Donald Trump are
they going to Riot as I've mentioned
before I supplement my diet with
vitamins every day I've tried different
methods none have been simpler or more
cost effective than just a daily scoop
of ag1 from our sponsor athletic greens
with the one scoop I get the 75 high
quality vitamins and minerals from whole
food sources that I want I'm covered for
the day I'm not messing around with
different vitamin capsules and then some
have 200 and some have 180 so they run
out at different times and it's a mess
it's a mess this is simple The Taste is
good you can put it in water juice or
shakes each serving is under three bucks
a day compare that to what all of the
individual supplements would cost you
and it just makes sense simplify your
life by starting the day with a scoop of
75 high quality nutrients when you go to
athletic greens.com
you'll get a free year supply of vitamin
see I've talked about vitamin D before
and five free travel packs of ag1 the
link is down below